sie will was machen aus ihrem Leben und
ackert seit Jahren für ihren
Hauptschulabschluss extrem schwer für
Jule sie leidet unter einem seltenen
Gendefekt dem Rett-Syndrom dadurch ist
sie in ihrem Körper gefangen kann sich
nur eingeschränkt bewegen und nicht
sprechen
was Sie mitteilen will muss sie
Buchstabe für Buchstabe auf einer Tafel
zeigen
dabei braucht sie wegen ihrer Lähmung
jemanden der ihren Arm am Ellenbogen
stützt ihre Hand und Finger entkrampfen
hilft
das kostet sehr viel Zeit deshalb hat
Jule vorab aufgeschrieben was sie uns
sagen will ihre Mutter spricht für sie
ich finde dass ich eine gute Denkerin
bin aber mein Körper ist kacke er macht
was er will mein Gehirn funktioniert das
möchte ich beweisen ich bin normal
schlau und auch mal Scheiße gelaunt
hier in ihrer ehemaligen Schule kam sie
mit Hilfe einer schulbegleiterin bis vor
einem Jahr gut klar in einem
Förderzentrum für körperbehinderte
Kinder innen drehen dürfen wir nicht
hier fühlte sich Jule bis zur siebten
Klasse gut gefördert
ihre schulbegleiterin Birgit Fries
durfte ihr stützend helfen auch bei
Klassenarbeiten ein sogenannter
Nachteilsausgleich der ihr per Gesetz
zusteht so konnte Jule nach dem
regulären Lehrplan der Hauptschule
unterrichtet werden und erreichte trotz
ihrer Behinderung gute Noten in allen
Hauptfächern eine 2
dann aber in der achten Klasse durfte
Birgit Fries bei Klassenarbeiten nicht
mehr stützend helfen plötzlich war Jule
auf sich allein gestellt warum
die zuständige Regierung Mittelfranken
begründet das mit einem schlimmen
Verdacht
es lässt sich nicht ausschließen dass
diese also die schulbegleiterin dem
Schüler auch inhaltliche Hilfestellungen
gibt
für Birgit Fries ist dieser Vorwurf
nicht nachvollziehbar und sie weiß den
klar zurück
wem so ist was bringen also wenn ich
jetzt vorsagen würde die ganze Zeit und
dann ist die Schule zu Ende
Schulbegleitung ist auch zu Ende in was
für ein Loch würde die Jule fallen es
kommt noch schlimmer die Lehrer in der
Förderschule dürften Jule offiziell zwar
unterstützen aber keiner wurde dafür
ausgebildet ohne diese stützende Hilfe
gingen Jules Noten in den Keller in
allen Hauptfächern eine vier im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr im Durchschnitt
von 1,9 auf 3,3
für die junge Frau die sich immer für
ihren Traum abgemüht hatte ein Disaster
so hat sie es für uns aufgeschrieben
aber so richtig
schlimm für mich
sie haben mich geärgert obwohl sie
wussten dass ich nur gestützt schreiben
kann diese Fieslinge ich muss viel mit
ihr auch arbeiten dass sie einfach
psychisch nicht verzweifelt und
psychisch nicht abbaut also weil sie
wirklich ganz arg traurig war über die
Situation
der Weg zum Schulabschluss mit
Behinderung voller Hindernisse
bundesweit hatten 2020 von rund 30.000
Abgängern von Förderschulen 22.000
keinen Hauptschulabschluss das sind 73%
aller Absolventen bedeutet drei von vier
Schülerinnen und Schülern an
Förderschulen haben null Chance auf eine
Berufsausbildung trotzdem existiert in
Deutschland jede zehnte Schule als
Förderschule oder Förderzentrum und das
obwohl Deutschland schon 2009 die
UN-Behindertenrechtskonvention
unterzeichnet hat bedeutet Kinder mit
Förderbedarf sollen auf Regelschulen
dass das nicht ausreichend geschieht
hält eine Expertin des Deutschen
Instituts für Menschenrechte für
rechtswidrig immer noch sind sechs von
zehn Kindern mit sonderpädagogischen
Förderbedarf in sonderstrukturen sprich
in Förderschulen untergebracht werden
dort unterrichtet dabei sind die
Vorgaben der
UN-Behindertenrechtskonvention klar
Deutschland ist verpflichtet ein
inklusives Schulsystem aufzubauen das
heißt nicht nur dass allgemeine Schulen
geöffnet werden müssen sondern auch dass
tatsächlich alle Kinder dort zusammen
unterrichtet werden und das
Förderschulen schrittweise abgebaut
werden
inklusive Unterricht ist nicht nur gut
für Behinderte sondern für alle Kinder
meint auch Marc ragles früher
Staatssekretär für Bildungen Berlin der
dazu kürzlich eine eigene Studie
veröffentlicht hat
internationale Studien und auch Studien
in Deutschland Europa haben bewiesen
dass das gemeinsame Lernen der
gemeinsame Unterricht von Kindern mit
und ohne förderbedarfen für beide Seiten
ein Gewinn ist also man lernt
tatsächlich auch als ein hochbegabtes
Kind in der Zusammenspiel mit anderen
Kindern deutlich mehr als wenn man in
geschlossenen hätte homogengruppen ist
und das gilt erst recht für Kinder die
vermeintlich behinderte Kinder sind
nach seiner Studie haben
förderbedürftige Schüler in Bremen
Schleswig-Holstein Berlin und Hamburg
eher gute Chancen durch inklusiven
Unterricht deutlich schlechtere haben
sie außer in Bayern in Baden-Württemberg
Sachsen-Anhalt Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
und Nordrhein-Westfalen
ein und hochziehen gemeinsam lernen in
NRW geht das hier an der Gesamtschule
Köln Holweide zum Beispiel auch mit
mehrfachbehinderten Kindern seit vielen
Jahren werden alle Arten von
Beeinträchtigung inklusiv unterrichtet
in der Klasse von Isabel Hahn sind fünf
Kinder mit Förderbedarf darunter mit dem
Schwerpunkt geistige emotionalsoziale
und Lernentwicklung in dieser
Deutschstunde ist eine zweite Lehrerin
dabei oft muss sie aber auch allein
klarkommen schwierig
im Vergleich zu anderen Kölner Schulen
haben wir eine etwas bessere personelle
Ausstattung die ist natürlich trotzdem
nicht wirklich gut es hat sich auch in
der Zeit in der ich jetzt hier bin ich
bin seit 17 Jahren hier in der Schule
hatte sich rapide verschlechtert meine
erste Klasse hier hatte 24 Kinder und
drei Förderschüler jetzt habe ich 27
Schüler und fünf Kinder mit Förderbedarf
trotzdem so berichtet sie funktioniere
Inklusion hier ziemlich gut
bewährt habe sich die Arbeit in kleinen
Gruppen wodurch sich die Kinder
untereinander helfen können jeweils drei
Klassen werden von einem Lehrerteam
sechs Jahre lang begleitet von der
fünften bis zu zehnten Stufe das erlaubt
flexible Lösungen und ein
vertrauensvolles Miteinander dennoch
gibt es häufig Bedenken von Eltern
förderbedürftige mit Schüler würden zu
viel Zeit und Beachtung auf sich ziehen
wie ist das hier in Köln Holweide
wir haben hier das nicht das Eltern
kommen und dieser sorgen äußern das ist
ganz im Gegenteil so dass viele Eltern
eher das als Vorteil betrachten dass ihr
Sonderpädagogen Unterricht sind und da
eigentlich ein Vorteil drin sehen auch
für ihre Kinder wenn sie keinen
Förderbedarf haben in dieser neunten
Klasse sind die Schüler schon im 5 Jahr
zusammen ihre Erfahrung fast alle halten
nichts von besonderen Schulen für Kinder
mit Förderbedarf
ist halt unnötig und doof dass die dann
ausgegrenzt werden
du brauchst ein bisschen mehr Hilfe als
andere ja
verstehe ich halt nicht dass jede
bekomme ich andere Aufgaben
sie kriegen halt nötige Unterstützung
für die Aufgaben und ja wir aber genauso
helfen dir deine Mitschüler auch
manchmal immer Menschen
die haben ihre Sachen wir haben unsere
Sachen aber wir lernen trotzdem alle
zusammen
hier in der 9 Klasse ist gemeinsames
Lernen selbstverständlicher Alltag
Inklusion mit positivem Ergebnis bis zu
drei von vier Schülerinnen und Schülern
mit Förderbedarf erreichen mindestens
den Hauptschulabschluss trotzdem werden
bis heute viele behinderte Kinder auf
Förderschulen abgeschoben nicht nur in
NRW hier muss man ganz klar sagen dass
der politische Wille fehlt und kein
klares Bekenntnisse und
unbehindertenrechtskonvention da ist bzw
die Verpflichtungen aus der Konvention
fehlt interpretiert werden in dem gesagt
wird die Förderschule ist ein
notwendiger Teil eines inklusiven
Schulsystems das ist aber klar
menschenrechtswidrig für Jule ist die
Förderschule kein Thema mehr ihre Eltern
fanden für Sie eine private Hauptschule
die sich um Inklusion bemüht
ob Jules schulbegleiterin ihr bei
Klassenarbeiten helfen darf oder ihre
neuen Lehrerinnen und Lehrer muss noch
mit der Regierung Mittelfranken geklärt
werden nur dann kann Jule zeigen was sie
wirklich drauf hat